[Música]
no es así
el 13 de mayo de 1888 en brasil fue
abolida la esclavitud fue uno de los
últimos países en el mundo en hacerlo
hoy en el centro de río de janeiro hay
una manifestación en contra del racismo
y de lo que llaman genocidio negro en
claro
la cree perpetrada por la policía en una
favela fue la semana pasada en la favela
de jacarezinho y murieron 28 personas
existió una abolición de la esclavitud
pero la población brasileña
especialmente la población negra
hoy en día sufre a manos del estado ya
sea por causa del hambre por las balas
por la subyugación por el racismo
entonces es una falsa abolición nos
dieron la libertad pero no tenemos una
libertad real
brasil es uno de los países donde hay
más racismo estructural la policía nos
mata a todos los días
legitimada por este estado que nos trata
como sospechosos
la favela no es sospechosa la favela es
un lugar que pide respeto
vargas traten de brasil y se celebró en
manifestaciones
8% de los gordos a manos de la policía
en paraná
tres policías que mueren de la periferia
y ocupan los cargos más bajos
datos que muestran
racismo estructural que en brasil está
borrado de muerte y desigualdad